qué recta muestra 360 y 1 544 veamos
todas comienzan en 361 ahora vamos a
agregar 544 esta comienza agregando 400
luego 50 y luego 4
es 454 1 544 aquí se agregan 500 luego
40 y luego 4
este está negando 544 a 361 y nos da 905
esto tiene sentido a 361 le agregamos
500 luego 40 901 y le agregamos 4 905
así que yo elijo esta opción en esta
opción de acá en lugar de sumar 500
estoy sumando 50 lo que no tiene sentido
ya que estamos agregando 5 centenas
cuatro decenas y cuatro unidades hagamos
otro ejemplo qué expresión puede
resolverse con la siguiente recta
numérica
veamos comenzamos con 718 luego le
agregamos 200 y después 40 para llegar a
958 esto es 718 + 240
esta opción de aquí hagamos otro ejemplo
esto es extrañamente divertido cuál de
estas rectas muestra 585 menos 368
veamos estas dos rectas numéricas
comienzan en 585 y la de arriba comienza
en 558 tiene los números intercambiados
y no tiene sentido vamos a enfocarnos en
estas dos opciones queremos restar 368 a
585 en ambos estamos restando tres
centenas luego tenemos que restar seis
decenas aquí estas seis decenas y luego
ocho unidades la opción correcta es esta
aquí en lugar de tener sesenta decenas
tengo 80 decenas y en lugar de tener
ocho unidades tengo seis unidades así
que se está restando 386 en lugar de 368
así que definitivamente esta última
opción es la correcta
hagamos un ejemplo más cual la expresión
ha sido resuelta usando la siguiente
recta numérica comenzamos en 935 luego
se restaron 400 o cuatro centenas y
después restamos 20 es 935 menos 420 935
menos 420 esta es la opción correcta